you've written actually on income
inequality yeah the Wall Street Journal
a piece that didn't get the attention
sellers thought maybe it deserved
you think this is a very big issue for
us I think it's a huge issue but I think
that I think we'll move in the right
direction on that over time and we have
an enormous way rich accommodative and I
mean well over 50,000 of GDP per capita
it's six times in real terms what it was
when I was born imagine that one
person's lifetime six for one is I mean
it blows your mind and if you told my
parents in 1930 while I was born that
there'd be this amount of poverty and
everything in the country that had grown
like that they would have left you and
the growing disparity it's not like it's
coming together now it's only the other
way it needs to be addressed because the
natural forces of a market economy and
capitalism will drive that disparity
unless government does things to help
and government has done things to help
over the years but it needs to do more
and you think earned income tax where to
go for us instead of increasing minimum
wage yeah it's nice if you get it but
but it also leaves less applause more
people on the point the clearing system
for labor is going to leave a lot more
people out of $15 an hour than where it
is now but the real the real thing
people need if you're poor is not a
higher minimum wage they need money
right Hannah and if they're willing to
work the earned income tax credits the
way to go up to tell you about organized
labor and whether it could play a role
in this the president you know is going
to have a summit in October yeah on
income inequality and he certainly is
including not exclusively but including
we're gonna say we're and I come from
Flint Michigan yes there for the for the
labor rights and a third is you know
yeah and the fact is UAW perhaps went to
successes but it really helped or
dissipate yeah and so for the fifties
and sixties now maybe that maybe that
doesn't work now but what do you think
about organized labor well organized
labor I mean there's no question that in
certain industries that the workers are
doing better than they would have done
otherwise and
that has some access in some places too
but but the real problem isn't the
people who fit in well which generally
the people in organized labor do with
our present system it's the people whose
skills just don't command much of a
market price and you can you can have
them all organized and it wouldn't do
any good in terms of making their skills
worth a whole lot more of this economy
but they are entitled it's the best they
could do is be a cleaning lady you know
god bless them they should they should
have a reasonable life in a country
that's prosperous and if you say the
minimum wage is $15 an hour my cleaning
lady is probably not going to have a job
but if you say we're going to change the
Earned Income Tax Credit so that if you
work 40 hours you're going to have the
income of a person that makes $15 an
hour that can be accomplished that
skills disparity takes us back to
education part of it because you look at
how a CD numbers at least it's not so
much that US education gotten worse just
the rest of the world's gotten a lot
better a lot better as the demands have
gone up in the marketplace yeah and so
what can we do about education that has
to be part of it you want everybody
educated to their potential you want
people to reach their potential that
still won't work for some people in a
highly developed market system I mean if
if this were a sports based system you
know you could give me a PhD in football
and I could practice eight hours a day
and I might be able to carry the water
from not onto the field but from the
locker room to the bed there's just some
people don't fit well and do a highly
skilled market based economy they're
perfectly decent citizens we'll send
them off to Afghanistan you know but
they are not going to command a bit but
you still want them to get the most out
of their abilities but if their
abilities leave them unable to learn
earn much more than the poverty level we
ought to do something additional form
we've got the resources so